events of the last couple of weeks must
have brought back all sorts of memories
for you have you dealt with it I have
never believed I will see a picture what
I should go through again and every
single happened to suggest crippled and
his daughter I still can't believe it
and of course but when it's all about
Russia and when it started to be broom
blamed Russia it's all took me back to
my experience to my life almost twelve
years ago we first met 12 years ago
didn't we I'm just shorter 12 years ago
how have you built rebuilt your life
since then I remember meeting you and
you were if you don't mind me saying you
were you were broken you had no idea
which way to turn your English wasn't
great because Sasha
Alexander had always you know been the
man of the house hadn't he he had been
this strong ox and we saw what happened
to him and how he deteriorated in
hospital but you have come from that
from that Mouse to rely on s that took
on a bear I can't believe he'd do this
again brilliant I remember this
everything what we did almost 12 years
ago at my first interview and now I have
to talk about since after 12 years and
it was from one side it was a good life
because I have my son who is grow up now
he's a young man 23 years old and I hope
he going to have a good future but
another side it was life of fighting
fighting for justice fighting from name
of my husband to prove everything what
he tried to say and to bring kind of
justice for what Sasha actually deserve
how do you remember those days 12 years
ago when he was in hospital and you
didn't know that it was split on him 210
until the very last minute did you it
was difficult because when you're
talking about seas and what do remember
but when it was in a pleasant days then
it was everyday hope every day hope he
will survive I believe the last moment
he realized and he was a fighter as well
he didn't know what is polonium-210 he
didn't know what kind of Roger activity
is killing him
but when there is have some kind of
medical treatment
we believed Sasha will survive but he
couldn't because after his death
polonium-210 was discovered and it was
explained to me from the first moment
Ashley held this fragile active material
did not enough to survive how worried
with you for yourself and for Anatole I
remember the time we did the interview
at my house because no London hotel
would let us film there because they
were worried that you were radioactive
are you absolutely right and after what
we received I I couldn't even imagine
what my life is going to be because
rather active polonium what does it even
police who started this investigation
they did tell me marina we don't know
how to handle this because nobody before
was killed by polonium 210 and all what
happened in my house should left house
even they did stay for 23 days stay in
the house before Sasha was poisoned
after Sasha was poisoned and only after
his death when polonium 210 was
discovered everybody understand how the
danger
I received some calls from my place
where I worked as a teacher if we need
to dis activate this place where you did
work and I just started to realize oh my
god what people might think about me
maybe I will lose all my communication
because this was frightening we were
waiting for tests from Health Protection
Agency because our son Anatoly couldn't
go to school all parents were again
very nervous what it might be even my
close contact received the same offer to
be checked because it might be again
nobody could understand how it might be
produced I was so glad not Anatoly not
any others have any polonium in their
body and I had slightly higher level but
doctor they said to me you mustn't touch
her you must not shake her hand the
glass that you drank from had to be
destroyed but when I saw you I you know
I wanted to hug you because you were you
were a broken woman so you know how
people who are related to those that are
caught up not just the those presently
in hospital but others who have
subsequently died must be feeling at the
moment I felt after what I went through
in one year particularly I just wanted
to see people who been nothing at the
same situation like me but the same in
hospital because Sasha was treated for
200 weeks in a Barnett hospital like
like a normal like a person having just
like some ordinary problems and of
course people around him all this
medical stuff they've been contaminated
too and I just try every time to
understand what these people came
through what was it difficult to them
and I remember when it was one year
anniversary I went to this hospital and
I went to the same unit when Sasha
started sees Oh his last days of his
life and I knew I was a little bit angry
then because people didn't treat him
from what actually Sasha had radiation
poisoning in some moments I was very
angry because nobody could explain me
what have
to them but when I came in one year I
just said thank you very much for
everything what you did even you didn't
know and it was very special for me
years on we are where we are do you
worry for your own safety and also for
the safety of Anatole you are very
outspoken but he is too he you know he
spoken to the newspapers he's even
written his own article hasn't he in the
Sunday Times yes but it's just started
for him he never been so active of
course he was young and I think you
tried to protect himself of not being so
outspoken because he wanted to be a
normal teenager he wanted to go to play
with his friends he wanted to go to
clubs and of course being recognized you
are son of Alexander Litvinenko in some
moments he didn't feel he is ready now
when he published his article under his
name Anatole little I was really proud
of this as a mom of course but then I
tried to see do I need to be frightened
or do I need to think more about my
safeties but I do what is a normal
person or woman who was your husband in
this way must do or can do but you seen
your friends
whose control but I believe for what
Sasha said before people might die
because it's all about money
unfortunately it was so difficult to
believe in 2002 when Sasha gave a lot of
interview and he was filmed by
international companies and he said
every time this new russia state without
any ideology has only one things it's a
money and if you stop them to earn money
in a way what they warn you might be
enemy of the state
what i said are not representing any
party in a financial corporation I'm not
about that and I hope it will not cost
something to my life your friend who
died last week and his death is not
being treated as a murder investigation
we're talking about nickel anguish cough
and when I received this news first
almost one week ago understand it looked
again I didn't know exactly all details
but I tried to think she was not killed
because I didn't like to understand if
somebody from this very special circle
of people here in London might be killed
and I was waiting for our police report
and then police report delivered he was
killed I was absolutely shocked because
this guy he was not so active smoking
compared to Boris Berezovsky because he
is from the same circle but he's still
fighting for his right in his own
business and I know he was in this legal
process was it price of what he did and
maybe he was killed for this I don't
know because it would be my opinion but
I believe investigation of his death
would be taking a very serious compared
to other people you know we can talk
about this list of people is new
these xiv names and it's not only
Russian this is British as well
nationalities but they have originally
not only it's a British British but
what's it strong link between all of
them it did business with Russian
President Putin has been speaking about
it and he has said it's absolute
nonsense to suggest that he or any of
his agents or representatives would be
in any way responsible for what has
happened both ways crippled in Salisbury
and also with with your friend who sadly
died absolutely nothing to do with the
Russian government or with him is it
anything new you received from mr. Putin
if he ever said yes we did it
they have just recent examples about an
extra of Crimea to remember how he
denied everything he said it was not us
it was not our military force but in two
years he said yes we did it and what and
what you're going to do and it's
actually it's his absolutely we how to
do this international community and his
foreign politics and for me it's it's
nothing new for what he said it's not as
do you hold him responsible do you think
he is responsive
all attitude what Russia produced now
after was saying yes this nerve agent
what was used against Sergei slip island
his daughter
it just shows yes he did it because not
any science of feeling to cooperate not
any science or think we are very sorry
for these people it's just a very
arrogant comments in so high level in a
foreign office I'm really ashamed I
don't like to see Russian diplomats or
Russian authorities or even Russian
president being like that
do you think he has a case to answer of
your friend's death again it's a
difficult to blame immediately person
but when you're talking about
people here just connected to Russian
business and if they cross this very
serious money thinks you might be killed
from these people from Russia because
how we know all government now control
by Security Service all they control all
sources as oil and gas and they
collected all this money from this
business and sometimes they even can't
imagine what kind of money we talking
about and why after very successful
moment when the price of oil was so high
Russia couldn't develop any better life
for their own citizen because most of
this money collected and used not for
speed but for their own lives what's
your view on the on the Russian election
he won again yesterday last night with a
landslide victory as some suggestions of
voting irregularity do you have a view
on that you know I try to think about
this and I thought people write I like
Russian people like everybody loves
Russian people they love Russian culture
they like Russian history and when they
see what happened during this election
and how Russian people support Putin go
to this and vote for him
I just try to remember what happened to
Russian people in Stalin era and they've
been the same they believed to this guy
and they believed he is a father of NASA
even he killed so many people and life
was so tough and it makes me feel very
very nervous about this because when it
was Brezhnev we can call this era in the
70s people been very cynical they
understand everything but saying through
all state channels is not true and
they've been more cynical but today some
of them not cynical really
believed wouldn't want to protect them
from West and best wants to destroy
Russia so you're comparing Protima
Stalin in a way even not putting Stalin
but how people believed and more about
this
I hope which I'm not going to kill
people like Stalin because we live in a
different era we live in a quite open
space and you can completely walk from
information but for what Putin does it's
very similar remind me this period of
time in Russia and ideology works in a
very similar way and I'm very very sorry
because if the Russian people believe in
him and so you don't think there were
irregularities with with the polling you
actually think that everyone that voted
voted for him because they think that he
is protecting them from the West not
everybody but some of them years and
when you can see picture of this Russian
people then it can ask them you see they
really believed it was really really
frightening me because educational still
not enough for people and just watching
state channels what absolutely
propaganda style and not collected any
other information it women make it
possible only hope it's a young
generation they're different so the only
hope is youngsters coming through yes
and but but he is president for another
six years now I think isn't it yes it's
supposed to we will see what is going to
be is he going to change Constitution or
he will take example of Chinese say to
change Constitution and stay forever I
don't know we will see but he has a lot
written as a possibility that he could
change the law again as he did with
Prime Minister and president in order to
be able to be in power until he does I
don't not be surprised not
price because siz this man represents
the special people around him it's just
not about mr. Putin it's more about
representation of people who supports
him on the his way who do you mean
mother because he couldn't do anything
himself without this support and we know
he represent a military people from
military authors people from security
office and there are some people from
intelligent service office and doesn't
mean they're all United is absolutely
different groups and he need to deliver
every single day people warned so he's a
mouthpiece to certain essence yes and
it's I can't see he has a very easy life
but for what we have no sympathy for him
absolutely about what he did for all
this 18 years
he's another slave of his system and why
she can't just say okay is the next
person to be after me because she can't
he builds his system and now she's
suffered from this but no somebody do
you think the British government is
doing enough to protect Russians that
have fled to the United Kingdom I would
be the first person who should criticize
British government but how I do
understand it's sometimes difficult to
understand what might happen because you
expect from Russia as civilian country
and playing on the same rules what does
international society plays but when you
do one step and show your old diplomacy
it doesn't mean from Russia side it
would be accepted everything for British
government did before it was taking as a
just very soft or even very weak and of
course Russia side didn't say we
to do anything and I hope next steps
what British government have to do has
to do it need to be more stronger then
in what way what can what can the
British government do what would you
like to see Therese and they do as a
result of what's happened in Salisbury
also what's potentially happened to your
friend I mean you've waited how long for
a public inquiry a dozen years yes but
again I just very optimistic person
maybe too much optimistic you and after
what happened to me but I think you need
to accept what you did not right and not
to do the same mistakes and then when
they try to try to talk what is a better
things to do I already mentioned it's
all about money if you want to punish
these people make it possible not to
spend their money here in Europe not to
accept this money to your business I'm
not talking about all Russia I'm talking
about certain people and it have to be
very personal sanctions and it's a very
serious moment when you say about
sanction but some people like people
from military office from security
series you could say they're ready not
travelling to UK or to Europe but
they're members or members of their
family they have everything here so you
think punitive financial sanctions
against certain people that have
benefited from the way Russia has been
run since the 1990s it's it's not new
because we're talking about Magnitsky
law what was provided by a medical state
it was accepted some European countries
but is not accepted here why why I have
this question why do you think it is I
think it is some if I may say some kind
of mentality if you have this money
you're able to invest to business here
in UK it's a good for country but now we
live in a different world they need to
understand what money you accept it so
basically we're taking blood money and
we need to not do that exactly you don't
need because you are going to describe
it as that how would you describe not
said you accepted this money you agreed
these people come to your country and do
what they want and means you give this
right then to commit this crime because
these people know they can do what they
want and it would be nothing nobody
would be punished because British
government just too good behaved and the
British government to a certain extent
has blood on its hands as well as a
results of allowing this money to flow
freely into the country but we need to
understand how this British government
worked all this time because when you're
talking about 18 years yes we could say
it was all time Putin but for this 18
years we had a few different Prime
Minister's they have a different
governments it should be very clear how
each government in the earth each period
what happened
can I ask you what you thought about
Jeremy Corbyn and some of the comments
that he made in the House of Commons
last week and I can't see people naive
but sometimes I hope is nothing behind
of this because I don't like to blame
people of being corrupted or do this
because of money what is very common
when you're talking about Russian
politics but again sometimes when you
meet people they try to think about
Russia in a in a better way and when
they try to give Russia another chance
or well she doesn't believe it might
happen to Russia I just had to
understand what he was being motivated
of his feeling he loves Russia or
because somebody asked him to do this
really difficult not only difficult to
blame him and
do you think he's naive no that the very
strange to say about politician for a
long time in the politics to be naive
and difficult you know you have to go
back to Russia I haven't not been for 18
years and every time when I think it's
time to go something happened like what
happened now is Sergey sleep I'll what
happened to Nicole a grush Cove and or
sometimes what happened inside of Russia
when I would say innocent people just
put to prison for post another Facebook
I could not believe and how is the old
loud system works but sometimes I think
it might be nothing happened to me and
when I come to Russia it would be
everything is fine I would be so sad
because I waste my time I could not see
my mom for a long time I couldn't go to
a funeral of my father you know it's
very difficult to understand what was
right to do what was not right because
it's all about people who are loves
I want power laughs and who ever want to
see him but I have my son here and I
don't think he will behave if something
happened to me in Russia and I just
tried to be in balance what I need to do
for now take a livin and talk to my mom
about my mom it's everytime very
difficult because she could travel to me
all this time but after my father day
that night he started to feel she's not
able to travel to anymore and she
believes everything is fine I can go to
Moscow nothing will happen to me and
it's it's more funny when she said
Marina don't say nothing don't say
something wrong
say mommy what do you think wrong don't
say something illegal I said what what
doesn't mean illegal but maybe it would
be against Putin or against this one as
in Miami I can't
and for her it would be I would shut up
I just go to Russia because she's just
wants me to be in Russia